montrer le vrai visage de l'agriculture
française c'est le but de ce
rassemblement d'agriculteurs qui devrait
avoir lieu aux alentours de 10 heures
ici aux invalides pour eux le vrai
visage c'est d'abord ce malaise qui
s'est installé dans l'agriculture
française selon le syndicat de la
coordination rurale
il y aurait deux suicides par
d'agriculteurs par jour et 1500m dépôt
de bilan par an ils dénoncent leurs
revenus qui sont selon eux parmi aller
plus bas de la société mais aussi un
sentiment d'isolement ce sont leurs mots
avec ce rassemblement ils entendent donc
mettre en lumière leur quotidien et les
difficultés auxquelles ils doivent faire
face
la dette de manifeste de cette
manifestation n'a pas été à laisser au
hasard puisqu'elle coïncide avec le
salon de l'agriculture qui aurait dû
ouvrir ses portes du 27 février au 7
mars mais entre temps le coc u19 a fait
son apparition et l'édition du salon
2021 a donc été annulée pour ces
agriculteurs de la coordination rurale
c'est donc en quelque sorte une date
symbolique
je propose d'écouter le président du
syndicat
le salon de l'agriculture a toujours été
une vitrine de l'excellence mais on y
parle de l'agriculture qu'à travers ces
tracteurs flambant neuf
ces drones et toutes les innovations qui
ne changeront rien vrais problèmes des
agriculteurs
le mal-être dans les campagnes ne doit
plus être tabou nous n'en pouvons plus
des prix bas et de cette écologie bête
et méchante qui impose des normes
toujours plus contraignante tout en
laissant rentrer sur notre territoire
des produits qui sont très loin de les
respecter
du côté du rassemblement ils devraient
débuter aux alentours de 10 heures ici
aux invalides s'en suivra à midi une
opération à un genou à terre
et puis à 13h les agriculteurs à
distribueront un manifeste dans
différents lieux de pouvoir